We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p.
Today's voicemail is depressing.
I did a segment earlier this week explaining
that there are lots of topics that I've been
self-censoring on because the audience reaction
just makes it not worth it.
One of those is I mentioned anytime I talk
about Tulsi Gabbert, people just attack me
for being a Shill, for smearing her, whatever
and that this doesn't happen with other Democratic
candidates so that I shy away from critiques
of Telsey Gabard.
Someone heard me explain this and they sent
me a voicemail saying they don't like my criticism
of Telsey Gabbert from that video, I didn't
criticize her.
This is proof in the pudding of exactly what
I'm talking about.
Take a listen to this.
Hello, this is Michael from Worcester.
Come on.
Tibet.
Um, I saw your video on this and you said
to yourself on the far left, I, I didn't like
your attack.
A tossing camper.
Okay.
She had some very valid ideas on foreign policy
and she gets way too much.
Hey,
this is exactly what I'm talking about.
I did not criticize Tulsi Gabbert in that
video.
What car, what attack are you talking about?
What I said in the video was when I talk about
or critique Tulsi, unlike with other candidates
who are polling 1% I am instantly attacked
for smearing her for being a shill.
If I critique any other candidate, the feedback
I get is about the substance.
You're proving exactly what I pointed out.
I can't even mention her name without people
saying, stop attacking Tulsi.
You don't like my attack on her.
I said nothing about her other than saying,
when I mentioned her, people attack me and
here you are doing it.
It's almost like a parody.
I it, I'm, I'm almost at a loss for words
because this is exactly the thing I was saying
in the video is what's going on.
And someone reacts by saying, I don't like
that attack on Tulsa.
There was no attack.
We're in serious trouble, folks, based on
this level of, uh, it seems like some kind
of compromise comprehension or some kind of
cult of personality that's creating a blind
loyalty were mentioning someone without glowing
apparently is now considered an attack.
I don't know.
But this is extreme,
narrowly depressing, Huh?
I'm not even going to tell you what's on the
bonus show.
It's a good bonus show.
I'm very rattled by that voicemail.
Uh, become a member.
The bonus show is a good one.
The David Pakman show@davidpacman.com.
[inaudible].